die wichtigste lockerung kurz vor dem
wochenende in vielen bundesländern haben
ab heute die restaurants wieder öffnet
hier in berlin gibt es gerade zu einem
großen ansturm auf die gastronomie ja
und mittendrin sitzt auch schon den
ganzen tag was für einen traumjob
mein kollege und zwar bild reporter
peter wilke hallo peter du bist in der
ständigen vertretung und da habe ich
gleich mal eine frage und zwar wie ist
es nach all dieser zeit endlich mal
wieder in seinem lokal zu sein
ja wir erinnern wie du schon gesagt dass
ein traumjob es ist super nach der
langen zeit endlich mal wieder unter
leute zu kommen natürlich unter der
strengen beachtung der hygieneregeln
aber es ist einfach wunderbar mal wieder
leute zu sehen nach der langen zeit wo
man nicht restaurants besuchen konnte
und ich konnte hier gerade schon mein
erstes bier trinken
ja es ist einfach toll ja das erste bier
in so einem lokal ist natürlich ein
besonderes gefühl
wir nehmen es die anderen gäste an wie
nimmst du so war ja die gäste nehmen es
auf jeden fall sehr gut an hier ist es
relativ gut gefüllt und die
hygieneregeln werden auch größtenteils
akzeptiert ich bin ja in der ständigen
vertretung direkt an der spree mitten in
berlin und hier hat man natürlich den
mindestabstand zwischen den tischen
eingehalten
es will sich regelmäßig die hände
desinfiziert und die nachbarn die
kellner tragen schutzmasken was hier
besonders ist dass an den eingang werden
gibt es einen qr-code denen die gäste
scannen können und dadurch mit kanten
die restaurantleiter nachvollziehen wer
bahrain gekommen ist und wer wann raus
um halt später die infektionskette
nachvollziehen zu können
peter du bist ja leider zur arbeit da
daher bleibt wahrscheinlich bei dem
einen schluck bier
aber hast du das gefühl dass die regeln
stören
nein die regeln stören eigentlich gar
nicht man muss sich halt damit abfinden
und sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnen wenn
man halt anderes gewohnt ist aber nein
die regeln ständig aber genau darüber
können wir auch mit einem gast sprechen
der hier sitzt nämlich daniel schneider
daniel seit etwa zwei stunden
und wie fühlt es sich an nach der langen
zeit endlich mal wieder in einem
restaurant zu sein
naja gut also die letzten zwei monate
waren schon sehr skurril auf mich also
unser büro sitzt schräg gegenüber und
die ständige vertretung war eigentlich
immer so ein ort wo man gerne mal abends
nach feierabend mit kollegen und
freunden was trinken war insofern das
war schon anders wir waren auch alle im
home office und insofern ja es ist schön
wieder hier zu sein und in köln zu
trinken temperaturen könnten etwas
wärmer sein
faktisch aber nee ist ein gutes gefühl
wann hast du denn beschlossen mit deinen
freunden hierhin zu kommen und wir
nehmen hier die hygieneregeln war also
eigentlich war das schon klar als wir
gehört haben dass die ständige
vertretung und wieder aufmachen darf wie
viele andere kneipen und restaurants in
berlin auf und das war ich keine große
frage dass wir uns natürlich heute hier
treffen
es ist natürlich noch was anderes wenn
man sieht dass die das personal hiermit
mit mundschutz rumläuft und gäste wir
die freunde kollegen sich nur mit
ellenbogen oder mit mit mit dem fuß
begrüßen können und dürfen
ja es ist ungewöhnlich aber es dennoch
schön wieder neben all den ganzen
videokonferenzen der letzten wochen
wieder reale gesichter vor einem zu
sehen uns ja auch ein pils trinken zu
können
ja verena wir nehmen wahr hier ist die
stimmung echt sehr gut mir sagte auch
der geschäftsleiter dass er endlich mal
wieder aufbruchstimmung spüren kann und
wir trinken jetzt noch hier unser
feierabendbier und damit zurück zu dir
ins studio
vielen herzlichen dank peter wilke
genießt ein feierabendbier unter ja in
berlin offensichtlich nehmen die gäste
ist ja gut an schauen wir doch mal wie
das in leipzig ist und zwar schalten wir
direkt rüber zu unserem reporter
maximilian tabak schinski maximilian
guten abend auch an dich du bist das
erste mal seit langem wieder in einem
restaurant ist muss ich kurz mal
nachfragen was hast du gestellt hier
gibt's heute schweine krustenbraten
kraut und klöße dazu eine wunderbare
braune soße ich sitze hier im leipziger
barfußgässchen das ist quasi mit einer
der ausgeben und wir sitzen im tunnel
ist ein gastronomie die gibt es schon
seit 1841 und ist natürlich ein
besonderes gefühl jetzt wieder nach so
vielen wochen in einem restaurant zu
setzen man gibt es mir vielleicht
eigentlich gleich einer der ganz gerne
in so ein restaurant sein gibt also ich
muss ehrlich sagen da wird man fast ganz
neidisch da steht ja auch noch ein
bisschen sieht alles auf jeden fall sehr
sehr lecker aus aber mal ganz ehrlich
wie sehr hast du es tatsächlich vermisst
im corona lockdown nicht den restaurants
zu gehen
ich persönlich bin jemand der gibt
machte arbeit ganz gern und hat sich
hier auch einfach schnell mal im
restaurant trifft sich mit freunden dort
kennt auch natürlich den einen oder
anderen gastronomen durch die arbeit vor
ort das ist dann natürlich alles
weggefallen und das ist einfach ein
moment wo man sagt endlich geht es los
hier wieder das ist auf der einen seite
schön auf der anderen seite ist das
heute noch ein bisschen schwierig weil
zum beispiel in leipzig die touristen
einfach noch fehlen also wir sitzen
jetzt hier direkt ins zentrum wo
natürlich die touristen normalerweise
auch oft stab bin und vielleicht kann
man es hinter mir sehen in dem
restaurant ist draußen kein einziger
tisch aber ich bin mir heute derzeit
noch der einzige gast und der chef hier
hat zehn leute ungefähr zu beschäftigen
heute und wenn ich der einzige gast bin
ist das natürlich schwierig absolut
schwierig da möchte ich auch gleich noch
mal nachfragen aber vorher zeigt uns
doch bitte ganz kurz noch mal dein essen
das sind einfach zu lecker aus wir
wollen genau wissen wie es aussieht ja
wohl dazu
man richtig appetit ich hoffe es wird
jetzt nicht kalt deshalb nur noch
schnell eine frage und zwar maximilian
was den gastwirt angeht du hast ja
gerade auch schon gesagt es sind sehr
sehr wenig gäste zufrieden kann er
eigentlich nicht sein oder
nein also natürlich nicht das problem
ist durch die 1 5 meter abstand
regierung die natürlich notwendig ist
hat er nicht mehr hat seine plätze die
eigentlich vorhanden hat es sind immer
anderthalb meter das heißt er verliert
hier mindestens 50 bis 60 prozent seiner
plätze das macht ganz schnell mal bis zu
150 plätze was da an umsatz weg geht das
ist dann halt wirklich problematisch das
war ich auf jeden fall hoffen wir das
jetzt in den nächsten tagen dass da
irgendwie voller wird hoffentlich
maximilian paczensky vielen herzlichen
dank und jetzt lass es dir schmecken
danke